Rusia habla de represalia con ataques de
precisión sin embargo vemos ataques
contra zonas residenciales y civiles Por
qué recurre Putin a este tipo de
ofensivas es una muestra de su poderío o
por el contrario de debilidad en estos
momentos de avance de los ucranianos en
el frente de batalla
mire estamos en presencia de una guerra
ya
totalmente definida y totalmente lanzada
esto es más que claro Entonces estamos
en presencia de algo que parecía que no
se tomó en cuenta las recientes
declaraciones de Putin que no iba a
aceptar ningún ataque terrorista en su
territorio especialmente en las zonas
fronterizas con la es república
ucraniana Y creo que esta respuesta ha
sorprendido absolutamente a todos aún a
los que gestaron este atentado sobre el
puente que une Ucrania Perdón que une
Rusia con este la Península de crimea
esto es una Clara demostración de que la
guerra se ha profundizar y de que a
partir de ahora es lo que dijo Putin
hace un par de meses
esta guerra recién empieza y estos son
evidentemente los resultados de este
bombardeo que se realizó esta madrugada
entonces usted comenta que considera que
este ataque masivo este bombardeo que se
ha producido hoy es una respuesta de la
explosión en el puente de crimea no se
trata entonces de un cambio en la
estrategia decidido previamente se trata
de una respuesta a lo sucedido del
sábado no estamos ante un regreso a la
guerra Total como al principio de la
ofensiva y por otro lado se han esfumado
ya las posibilidades de diálogo
vamos por parte lo primero es que
estamos en presencia de una gigantesca
guerra híbrida global que ya no
solamente involucra a la federación rusa
y en su momento a la República ucraniana
sino como todos sabemos que esto es un
enfrentamiento y le dicen todos los
analistas que es un enfrentamiento otan
que encabeza Estados Unidos de
Norteamérica y la federación rusa y
detrás de la federación rusa un sector
de los países llamados potencias
emergentes como es Rusia India China
etcétera
y por otro lado rápidamente contempla
usted la posibilidad de que Rusia llegue
a usar armas nucleares como han
advertido tanto biden como Celeste
yo creo que eso es una es un relato que
ha lanzado algunos poderes de occidente
el mismo Pentágono ha desmentido la
declaraciones de vaiden diciendo de que
no tienen ningún dato de que hayan
movilización de tipo de armamento
nuclear ruso hacia la fronteras con
Ucrania por lo tanto forma parte de un
relato propagandístico de guerra que no
podemos asumir los analistas en serio
cuando vemos este conflicto que ya se
podría ver solucionado hace varios años
atrás y de que no se ha logrado Porque
alguien alguien impidió que se
alcanzaran y se lograrán el cumplimiento
de los dos acuerdos de paz que se firmó
en el 2014-2015